[Musique]
bienvenue dans les bas sur france 24
c'était il ya un an jour pour jour des
partisans de donald trump envahissait le
capitole le sanctuaire du congrès
américain à washington
joe biden a pris la parole il a mis
l'accent sur la responsabilité des
assaillants et de donald trump l'assaut
du capitole était une insurrection armée
a martelé le président américain et
donald trump à créer un tissu de
mensonges au détriment de l'intérêt du
pays donald trump lui a répondu dans un
communiqué et dénoncé un théâtre
politique de joe biden pour faire
oublier ses échecs
un an après alors la démocratie
américaine est elle menacée quel impact
sur le leadership américain dans le
monde que peut faire joe biden président
impopulaire à un an après le début de
son mandat et puis finalement donald
trump prépare-t-il un retour en 2024 on
va démarrer cette discussion avec à mes
côtés françois durpaire bonsoir
historien spécialiste des états unis
auteur de la bd le dernier livre et
c'est chez glénat remercie d'être avec
tout françois gauthier rybinski est avec
nous notre chroniqueur internationale
france 24
nous avons également gérald ollivier
journaliste franco américain
éditorialiste à atlantico chercheurs
alips et auteur je cite votre livre
gérald sur la route de la maison blanche
aux éditions donc jean picollec
merci bonsoir
christian henn lait est avec nous en
direct de washington c'est vous qu'on a
vu il ya un instant christian consultant
politique auprès du parti démocrate
merci d'être avec nous bien venu
également dans le débat merci et puis à
washington également on dit plat que
cette fois sonia dridi notre
correspondante bonsoir sonia
avant de démarrer c'est de vous propose
d'écouter un extrait justement du
discours de joe biden s'était il y à
quelques instants
what they will nachi qu'est ce qui n'a
pas été un ancien président qui venait
d'inciter la foule a attaqué à six dans
sa salle à manger à côté du bureau ovale
de la maison blanche en train de
regarder ça à la télévision et ne
faisant rien pendant des heures alors
que la police était attaquée que des
vies étaient menacées que le capitole
était assiégée
si
sonia sonia dridi à washington bailon
mais vraiment clairement l'accent sur la
responsabilité de donald trump dans cet
assaut
oui c'est vrai parce que joe biden qui
lui pendant près d'un an a tenté plus
tôt d'user le mépris vis-à-vis de donald
trump de ne jamais le mentionner et bien
c'est dans ce discours ça a été un
discours très à charge contre l'ancien
président d'ailleurs il a cité l'ancien
président 16 fois sans jamais le nommer
il a notamment déclaré la vérité c'est
que l'ancien président a diffusé une
série de mensonges sur l'élection de
2020 parce que son ego blessés à plus
d'importance pour lui que la démocratie
il a aussi décrit un donald trump qui a
appelé ses partisans à se rassembler au
capitole le 6 janvier dernier et ensuite
qui a regardé la taca la télévision sans
ne rien faire alors que des policiers se
faisait agresser et puis il a aussi
tenté d'interpeller ceux qui ont
tendance à minimiser cette attaque par
exemple un récent sondage montre que 25
% des américains pensent que ceux qui
ont investi le capitole il y a un an et
bien on tenté de protéger la démocratie
et joe biden a rappelé certaines scènes
hallucinantes auquel on a assisté il y a
un an avec des insurgés qui ont usé des
drapeaux américains comme lens des
policiers qui se faisait piétiner
c'était vraiment important pour joe
biden de rappeler les faits on sent
aussi que avec ce discours il a tenté
d'imprimer un tournant plus politique
plus grave alors que les élections de
mi-mandat approche on sent qu'il essaie
de motiver sa base électorale est aussi
qu'il a compris qu'il ya une part de la
population américaine qui ne changera
pas d'avis selon un récent sondage on
voit que quelques 55 % des américains
seulement pensent que joe biden a été
élu légalement sans fraude donc joe
biden qui s'est toujours posé comme un
rassembleur qu'il a dit au début de son
mandat qu'il voulais unifier les
américains on sent qu'il a aussi compris
que ça allait être un défi très
compliqué et finalement il y a un an
après ces images qui ont bouleversé une
partie du pays et du monde est bien
certain penser après cette journée que
peut-être cela allait provoquer un
électrochoc que les parties allaient se
rapprocher les différents partis et
finalement non on sent que la démocratie
est plus fragilisée que jamais
aujourd'hui aux états unis merci sonia
françois durpaire comment l'avez vous
trouvé joe biden justement c'est un
discours effectivement offensif
partisans un an après on a presque envie
de dire c'est presque trop tard
oui mais il faut quand même se souvenir
qu'il y a un an il était intervenu
l'avait déjà fait un discours ce jour là
et se disent qu ils avaient mis
d'ailleurs toute la journée à le
préparer on a beaucoup mis l'accent sur
la manière dont donald trump a réagi à
ces événements il ya un an n'a peu
relevé la manière dont lui joe biden qui
était président élu avait réagi aux
événements alors on le sait maintenant
ils étaient moigne âge qui disent il
était chez lui tout simplement il a
assisté ça à la télévision il est dit
donald trump et était devant sa
télévision lui aussi était devant sa
télévision et les mots qui reviennent
c'est qu'ils avaient été choqués qu'ils
avaient été abasourdi et horrifiés par
ce qui se passe est que très rapidement
il a voulu faire un discours devant les
américains et vous rappeler de cette
phrase une bataille pour l'âme de la
nation il avait pris conscience de
l'enjeu pour la démocratie américaine
alan l'historien elle est quand même
prudent parce que la démocratie est en
danger oui mais pas plus que dans les
années soixante du 19e siècle y avait
une guerre civile ou pas plus que dans
les années soixante du xxème siècle où
kennedy s'était fait assassiner son
frère également il y avait quand même
une décennie sera difficile aussi pour
la démocratie en revanche ce qui s'est
passé le 6 janvier ça effectivement ça
reste inédit dans l'histoire du pays le
fait
l'envahissement du coeur de la
démocratie américaine
ça c'est quelque chose qui reste une
empreinte forte et sonia le disait ce
qui est intéressant c'est qu'il n'y a
pas aujourd'hui un an après de consensus
autour de ce qui s'est passé et on
rajoute juste d'un mot un sondage
important chez les républicains deux
tiers des républicains aujourd'hui
considèrent que ce qui s'est passé est
une attaque à la démocratie américaine
lient considère en fait que c'est au
contraire une défense des libertés
pourquoi parce qu'il continue à penser
que cette élection de 2020 a été volé a
été donnée à donald trump c'est quand
même assez incroyable
christian année à vous qui êtes proche
des démocrates comment l'avez vous
trouvé joe byden il être bien dit tout
de même que finalement la seule du
capitole était une insurrection armée il
l'a martelé c'était important d'avoir un
discours offensif et partisan
aujourd'hui la part du président
américain
absolument en fait c'était un discours
bien sûr offensive mais partisans n'ont
pas tellement sauf si on compte que la
vérité est
et est à fait partisan pour les
démocrates mais non en fait je le dis ce
fonds c'est quelque chose d'important
parce que un an après le 6 janvier ils
font il faut souligner les chais
de ce jour là en fait ce que l'on voit
ici aux etats unis c est un parti chez
les républicains
qui n'existe plus dans notre réalité
partagez donc comme on a vu à nous comme
dans les années soixante du 19e siècle
on est existe maintenant dans ce pays
dans deux réalités complètement
différent même à un niveau très simple
quant au fait du 6 janvier de l'an
dernier donc fou le président c'était
très important d'avoir de faire un
discours qui était capable de souligner
les chais établi que le 6 janvier de
l'an dernier c'était à un attentat
vraiment un acte criminel de la part
de l'ancien président dans la 30e et que
ce n'est pas
à simple manifestation comme disait
l'ancien président ce matin gérald
olivier vous qui connaissait bien
justement les républicains comment
expliquer que une grande majorité des
républicains pensent toujours que cette
élection a été volée à donald trump
mais c'est très simple c'est parce que
pour eux la lumière n'a jamais vraiment
été faite sur ce qui s'est passé la nuit
du vote et dans les journées qui ont
suivi le vote et dans les journées qui
ont précédé le vote c'est à dire que
souvenez vous de la nuit du 3 au 4
novembre
lorsque donald trump va s'coucher en
quelque sorte il est minuit et une heure
du matin il est largement en tête à ce
moment là on arrête le décompte dans un
certain nombre de bureaux de vote et au
petit matin on apprend que là où il
était en tête il ne l'est plus et là où
il est encore en tête on nous dit qu'on
ne connaît pas les résultats définitifs
parce qu'il va falloir compter les votes
par correspondance que ce vote pendant
plusieurs jours que les bulletins de
continuent à arriver et qu'à l'arrivée
après plusieurs jours et des délais qui
sont totalement je dirais inhabituelle
dans le contexte américain
c'est joe biden qui est déclaré
vainqueur mais qu'est ce que voulait
dire gérald olivier que justement met en
doute ce comptage parce qu'en fait ils
comptaient les vols comme vous le disait
un des votes par anticipation et les
votes par correspondance
les républicains mettent en doute deux
choses la première c'est un certain
changement des règles électorales qui
ont été rendues possibles sous le
prétexte du corps ide et qui ont
facilité le vote par correspondance dont
on sait pertinemment qu'il est beaucoup
moins fiable je rappelle que d'un pays
comme la france le vote par courrier est
interdite depuis 1975 oui enfin ça c'est
vous qui le dites mais il me semble en
fait aux états unis disent qu'il n'y a
pas vraiment il n'ya pas de fraude en
fait dans les votes par correspondance
et lisses et peau on sait très bien que
c'est faux mais si vous voulez ce que
les démocrates n'ont pas fait les
démocrates ont voulu entériner la
victoire de joe biden qui était une
victoire qui était inscrite dans les
chiffres parce qu'il a eu 81 millions de
votes pour lui et
trump dans n'a eu que 75 donc écart au
décompte des voix était important mais
comme chacun sait aux etats unis les
élection est une élection l'élection
présidentielle est une élection au
suffrage est indirect ce qu'il faut
c'est remporter le vote au collège
électoral est là le vote était beaucoup
plus serré et il y a eu un certain
nombre de contestations et les
démocrates auraient dû jouer la
transparence directs et 5 et marine
n'ont pas été transparent ergoter notre
pression pour que l'on sache vraiment ce
qui s'est passé et à partir de là il y
aura pas de contestation mais c'est pas
ce qui s'est passé et c'est pourquoi une
base républicaine et un certain nombre
de citoyens républicains et américains
aujourd'hui considèrent que les
circonstances de cette élection reste
flou gauthier rybinski alors
effectivement les circonstances sont
vraiment véritablement fou parce qu on
se souvient de ces trois jours de
comptage ou effectivement les
républiques à une partie de la
population américaine en mettant en
doute la fiabilité des résultats mais au
final moi on me disait toujours il n'ya
pas de fraude aux états unis de
m'écouter alors d'abord sur le vote par
correspondance ou il n'y a pas de preuve
ou d'études de sérieux sur le fait qu'il
y eu fraudes massives par le passé
concernant le front le vote par
correspondance mais ce qui me paraît
plus important c'est que je ne suis pas
persuadé ou alors que ce soit plutôt un
paravent ou une manière d'avancer masqué
mais je ne suis pas persuadé que les
républiques du moins ceux qui ont été
partie prenante dans l'assaut du
capitole es tu pour envie ou pour idée
de défendre la démocratie je pense que
il avait fait litière et déjà leur deuil
d'une certaine démocratie et que si ils
ont avancé s'ils ont progressé en disant
qu'ils étaient là pour la défendre
c'était puces par finalement j'allais
dire presque x esprit de marketing
pardonnez-moi mais plus pour finalement
se blottir dans un dans un caractère
républicain et constitutionnelles
qu'avec la volonté de défendre cette
démocratie qui de toutes manières leur
apparaît comme néfaste comme éminemment
contestable donc si vous voulez je pense
que c'est pour ça aussi que c'était
l'existence de cette contestation du
vote
du début novembre est utile à ceux qui
se sont révoltés qui ensuite ont mené
cette action ç'a leur donner un prétexte
une légitimité pour agir mais je pense
que fondamentalement c'était simplement
un prétexte et qu'ils étaient d'ores et
déjà sur cette pente qui vise à
contester et même de manière radicale et
violente
un pouvoir qui celui-ci ou un autre leur
semble illégitime à partir du moment où
il est démocrate françois durpaire
justement sur cette question du comptage
des votes mis en doute un même gérald
olivier dit il n'y a pas eu suffisamment
de transparence était tout un débat il y
a un an
le horse est pas républicaine contre
démocrate on se rappelle que le
président de la commission en charge de
l'élection n'était pas un démocrate
c'était un républicain il l'a déjà même
été ensuite il a mis sa démission dans
la balance pour dire écoutez si le
président continue à considérer que
cette élection ait été truquée non il
n'y a pas de trucage et la justice
américaine à différents déchets là a dit
la vérité judiciaire
il n'y a pas eu de trucages et il cette
élection effectivement est une élection
qui a été contesté par donald trump de
longs mois avant même l'élection il a
préparé en quelque sorte la contestation
en disant de toute façon à partir du
moment où il va y avoir un vote par
correspondance
vous allez voir qu'on va me voler cette
élection cirque il a contesté le
fonctionnement par correspondance en
disant ce n'est pas démocratique
les analyses de la politique américaine
avait décrit ce qui allait se passer en
dix ans ce jour là il y aura ce qu'on
appelait d'ailleurs à l'époque un mirage
rouge on va voir la carte en rouge des
états unis c'est à dire les gens qui se
sont déplacés qui sont plutôt
républicain et bien tout simplement va
faire une carte qui sera une carte
républicaine sauf qui va falloir
attendre le décompte des votes par
correspondance qui étaient en majorité
démocrate et vous vous en souvenez il y
avait à l'époque une sorte de scission
politique entre les républicains qui
était vous rappeler en plein coeur de
lakovic 19 non masqué qui étaient prêts
à aller voter démocrate beaucoup plus
timoré prudent qui votait plus tôt par
correspondance tout ça était donc au
coeur de cette pandémie mais en même
temps la démocratie et est passé et
comme l'a dit gerald il ya eu un écart
très important en terme j'allais à
démographique qui se traduit pas
nécessairement selon le collège
électoral mais cette décision du 6
janvier elle est très importante parce
que ce n'est pas un république ce
n'était pas un démocrate qui fait
pencher la balance c'est le vice
président des états unis d'amérique qui
n'est pas un démocrate et qui n'est pas
non plus la gauche du parti démocrate
et c'est ça que d'ailleurs donald trump
lui reproche en dix ans la maille pence
il aurait dû être de notre côté mais ce
qui compte c'est quand même un an après
d'un mot un an après ce qui se passe
c'est que 57 personnes qui ont joué un
rôle ce 6 janvier sont aujourd'hui
candidats aux futures élections mi terme
ça veut dire que en quelque sorte pour
le parti républicain il y a des gens qui
non seulement ne sont pas disqualifié
parce qu'ils ont participé au 6 janvier
mais qui utilise ça comme un tremplin
politique et il y a aussi des
conservateurs du parti qui font le tour
des chaînes et conservatrice américaine
pour dire écoutez cette élection il
répète que cette élection a été volé
c'est ça les utilisent ils ont continué
à alimenter en et casque et une phrase
quand même l'extrémisme et normalisé à
l'intérieur du parti républicain c'est
pas quelqu'un d'extrême gauche qui dit
ça c'est mickaël brodkorb qui est
l'ancien vice président du parti
républicain du minnesota qui dit il ya
quelque chose qui est en train de se
passer dans le parti républicain en
quelque sorte le 6 janvier n'a pas été
la fin du trump heist mais le début d'un
héros 36 mhz et christiane losc
justement sur cette fiabilité juste pour
terminer cette question est-ce qu
effectivement les démocrates auraient dû
être plus transparent est ce qu'il ya eu
à ce qui a eu des erreurs de commises au
tour justement pendant ces trois jours
où il y avait ce comptage des voix par
correspondance et des voix par
anticipation après on sait que la
pennsylvanie a basculé a fait basculer
et que effectivement c'est joe biden qui
a gagné cette élection mais comment
expliquer qu effectivement une grande
majorité grande on était des américains
d'après ce que j'ai vu pense que donald
trump est responsable en partie de
l'assaut mais c'est vrai que les
républicains ceux qui votent
républicains pensent toujours que
l'élection ait été truquée
et bien c'est le président mbaye dunn
qui l'a dit ce matin c'est une série de
mensonges
qui viennent de la bouche de donald
trump c'est pour ça qu'il ya tant de
deux auteurs des lecteurs il ya tant de
républicains qui croient vraiment que
cette élection a été volée de dallas 30
il n'y avait pas de problème de
transparence pas de problème de fraude
il y avait il y avait absolument rien
que le parti démocrate roi ait pu faire
pendant ces trois jours l'an dernier
donc ce que l'on voit ici maintenant
c'est cette division entre nos deux
réalités
il y avait un autre invité tout à
l'heure qui vient de dire que gagner
une série de deux
pardonnez-moi de chaîne conservatrice a
ici aux etats-unis qui que les électeurs
républicains regarde tous les soirs
donc pour eux ils consomment cette
réalité cette histoire cette fiction qui
fait pas partie de la préhistoire de
l'élection de 2020
et donc c'est pas une question de
transparence de la part de la part de la
part du parti démocrate c'est une
question des mensonges qui viennent du
parti républicain trappistes et c'est
vrai que le 6 janvier c'est vraiment le
début je crains du 36 mhz au coeur de
notre démocratie et de dans le parti
républicain parce que c'est pas dans
notre up lui même qui me fait peur c'est
c'est le prochain candidat c'est
quelqu'un qui a qui a créé les leçons de
la candidature de donald trump en 2016
et puis en 2020 mais c'est quelqu'un qui
va être pu
plus intelligent pu je capable qui sera
probablement
qui posera probablement un danger
beaucoup plus grand pour notre
démocratie que dans la trump jr
l'olivier le parti républicain est donc
de num résolument trump heist parce qu
on se souvient que les républicains
juste après l'assaut justement au
capitole mitch mcconnell rossi avait
parlé des responsabilités donald trump
et puis un certain nombre de
républicains qui avaient voté d'ailleurs
pour l'hymne pitch monte de donald trump
même s'il n'y avait pas eu la majorité
au sénat et aujourd'hui on a
l'impression qu'ils sont tous derrière
donald trump un an après
oui donald trump a gardé la main sur le
parti républicain et il a une base
auprès de auprès de qui il reste
extrêmement populaire en plus on
reconnaît la personnalité qu'il a et à
partir de ce moment c'est très très
difficile à qui que ce soit au sein du
parti de chercher à le défier on
remarque qu'il y à quelques personnages
qui ceux qui se démarquent un petit peu
par exemple le sénateur ted cruz qui est
sénateur du texas et dont on sait qu'il
a des ambitions présidentielles
mais pour 2024 il est presque acquis que
donald trump voudra avoir une chance
pour sa revanche et qu'il reste le
candidat principal du parti maintenant
je suis pas forcément d'accord avec tout
ce que j'ai entendu par mes différents
collègues ce qui est certain c'est que
l'histoire est écrite par les vainqueurs
et les démocrates ont remporté
l'élection présidentielle de 2000 20 et
à partir de là il est acquis que pour
eux elle n'a pas été volé de même qu'il
est acquis et votre vos reportages et le
vocabulaire que vous employez le
démontre que pour vous et pour tous ces
gens-là ce qui s'est passé le 6 janvier
c'était une insurrection armée et ce
n'est pas le cas on a vu d'autres
insurrections armées il ya eu une
résurrection armés la nuit dernière au
kazakhstan regarder de quoi ça a l'air
ça n'a absolument rien à voir c'est une
manifestation qui a dérapé et qui a
repoussé de quelques heures le processus
électoral et dire que les républicains
ont fait une croix sur la démocratie
c'est complètement faux la preuve comme
le rappelait françois durpaire sait que
c'est en effet le vice-président qui le
6 janvier dernier était là pour remplir
son rôle de vice président et de
prononcer les résultats de l'élection
après débats du congrès et au besoin
quelques objections et ce processus a
été interrompu par l'envahissement du
produit du congrès mais manifestement
les gens qui étaient là étaient pas là
pour prendre pouvoir parce qu'ils ont
fait quelques selphy à l'intérieur et
ils sont ressortis derrière et le
processus après a pu reprendre son cours
est née quand même on peut remarquer que
voir les démocrates dénoncer ces
violences alors que pendant toute
l'année 2020 ils ont au contraire
conscio né des violences beaucoup plus
grave dans toutes les métropoles
américaines qui ont été incendiés qui
ont été pillées dans les commissariats
ont été attaqués qui ont causé la mort
de plus de 25 personnes alors qu'il ya
eu quatre décès le jour du 6 janvier et
qui étaient tous parmi les manifestants
et là ça m'a presque au lycée aussi
clément femmes étaient désarmés qui a
été tué par un policier donc à mon avis
il faut que les shows il faut ramener
les choses à leurs justes proportions et
les républicains il ya un an ont été
choqués par les images parce que c'est
vrai qu'elles sont très inhabituelles et
qu'il est totalement inadmissible
d'investir un style capitole n'y a aucun
doute là dessus par contre lorsqu'on a
un petit peu de recul et qu'on regarde à
froid on s'aperçoit qu'il ya un certain
nombre de responsabilités qu'elles ne
sont pas toutes autres les marques de
doigts d'un trump et que là on a une
instrumentalisation tout à fait logique
de cette journée à des fins politiques
est l'un des disqualifiés donald trump
voire de parvenir à le bannir et à lui
interdire de se représenter alors c'est
qui les états de la commission qui a été
mise en place gauthier alors justement
cette commission un gauthier cette
commission d' enquête de la chambre elle
a toujours pas rendu ses conclusions ça
fait un an qu'elle siège de départ ça
devait être une commission bipartite
finalement me semble-t-il un certain
nombre de républicains s'y sont opposés
donc on se retrouve avec deux
républicains au sein de cette commission
dont d'ailleurs liz cheney la fille du
vice président de bouche de dick cheney
où en est on gaultier parce que là on
voit le débat sur ce plateau on voit que
effectivement l'amérique est fracturée
que les démocrates et les républicains
ne sont pas toujours pas d'accord sur
cette élection la commission doit elle
rendre des conclusions rapidement pour
donner justement elle vers la lumière
elle aurait d'intérêt même pour sa
propre crédibilité dans la mesure où on
peut craindre que si les républicains
remporter les élections de mi-mandat il
aurait vite fait est au fait de
supprimer cette commission et ce comité
donc effectivement il y aurait il y
aurait intérêt bros connaît ce qu'on n'a
pas dit peut-être de manière suffisante
c'est que l'accès documents par exemple
de de donald trump a été très difficile
voire impossible pour vous pour ce
comité parce que donald trump a empêché
pour fêter un accès tout à fait et que
donc il ya cette position bizarre de
donald trump qui est à la fois
finalement de ne pas aller jusqu'au bout
de ses opinions c'est à dire en
défendant cette démarche tout en l'ayant
initiés puisque on a bien vu ce discours
qu'il tient avant les événements du
capitole où il dit nous allons descendre
l'avenue de pennsylvanie nous allons
aller jusqu'au capitole bien il faudrait
être sourd et idiot pour ne pas pour un
manifestant un partisan de top de ne pas
avoir compris l'invite et l'exhortation
donc on peut bien sûr après discuter de
de la manière dont les démocrates
espèrent finalement que ce comité que
cette commission vont les remettre en
selle peut-être pour les élections on
espère aussi deux soeurs de ce côté là
que les dissensions au sein des
démocrates pourraient être dépassés
parce que c'est vrai que les dissensions
des divergences de vues au sein du parti
démocrate sont un handicap pour les
futures élections mais sur la
matérialité des faits de ce 6 janvier
2021 il y à un continuum qui ne peut pas
faire penser que les démocrates auraient
serait parvenu à tendre un piège donald
trump a bien tenu le discours qu'il a
tenu et ses partisans l'ont entendu
françois durpaire quel impact pour
avancer un petit peu justement sur le
leadership américain dans le monde que
cette fracture on voit bien que
l'amérique est fracturée tout de même
qu'à l'impact joe biden a évoqué dans
son discours il a dit il faut un combat
des démocraties contre les régimes
autoritaires il avait organisé un sommet
il ya quelques mois justement visant
poutine ou encore si jean ping qui eux
évidemment utilisent ces images en
disant que la démocratie américaine est
morte qu'elle ne vaut plus rien à que la
limite les vrais régime c'est jean ping
10 et nous la vraie démocratie difficile
du coup d'assurer un leadership oui
c'est compliqué parce que joe biden
cherche à remettre le mot démocratie au
coeur de sa politique étrangère on sait
que chaque président veut avoir une
doctrine en politique étrangère lui
l'avait utilisé ce terme il avait dit
c'est le retour de l'amérique et de la
démocratie américaine sauf qu'évidemment
il ya la question de l'est en plat rites
et de cette démocratie à partir du
moment où le monde entier voit cette
démocratie fonctionner telle qu'elle
fonctionne c'est à dire difficilement et
bien les régimes qui sont opposés à
l'amérique et là c'est pas une guerre
froide déjà leader sino américaines il
ya un tandem aujourd'hui on le voit bien
c'est le problème de joe biden un tandem
entre les russes et les chinois donc
c'est une guerre froide en quelque sorte
une guerre froide qui n'est pas terminée
33 ans après la chute du mur de berlin
celle avec la russie et une autre qui
s'annonce qui est celle avec la chine et
pour compliquer la chose est bien les
problèmes entre ces deux pays justement
il les met un peu de côté pour faire
front commun contre les états unis donc
on a et ça se déplace et d'ailleurs il
ya aussi la question de la caq contre
les démocraties occidentales de la part
de ces régions puisque pour le dire
d'une formule très simple le prochain
pearl harbour il sera numérique et que
les attaques en matière de cybersécurité
c'est ce qui préoccupe principalement
les équipes de renseignement notamment
américains c'est vrai mais alors
christian hecq justement comment
défendre la démocratie quand on est soi
même attaqué en son sens c'est pas
facile pour joe biden
non c'est pas facile du tout est en fait
ya la question des cyber sécurité la
question de
[Musique]
d'attac d'information et fait que nous
donc il n'attaque qui vient de la russie
tous les jours par internet ici dans
notre pays donc pour lui d'abord il faut
avoir une démocratie forte ici chez nous
comme exemple parce que pour la chine
ainsi que pour la russie et les exemples
de violences politiques ici aux etats
unis savent très bien en tant que
propagande pour leur régime chez eux et
en même temps il faut avoir
un système de sécurité numérique ici
dans notre pays beaucoup plus fort que
ce qui existe actuellement donc que ce
soit au niveau
des réseaux sociaux ou même de
l'actualité que l'on voit ici sur
chaîne d'information il faut avoir un
système qui n'existe pas encore un
système de sécurité numérique et pour
protéger la démocratie pour la
démocratique pour que ça existait pour
que ça fonctionne il faut qu'il y ait
des citoyens et les citoyennes qui sont
bien informés et éduqués et
malheureusement ce que l'on voit tous
les jours ici aux etats unis c'est les
efforts surtout de la part de la chine
et de la russie de détruire notre
cohésion nationale par des attaques
numériques et de mauvaises informations
par des réseaux sociaux donc ça va être
une stratégie à la fois numériques et
politique pour l'administration de baden
et gérald olivier donc il y à une
attaque en plus alors une bien ces
problèmes de la démocratie interne aux
états unis démocratie fracturée et puis
aussi donc l' attaque de la part donc de
la russie de la chine joe biden aimerait
bien d'ailleurs que toutes les
démocraties puisse faire bloc contre les
régimes autoritaires et ce n'est pas
simple en fait parce que les démocraties
n'ont pas toutes les mêmes objectifs
non absolument leurs vies sauvées pour
les états unis en fait protéger la
démocratie pour moi est très simple et
est la première étape l'étape
essentielle qu'il faudrait parvenir à
faire avant les élections de mi mandat
c'est de parvenir à rétablir une pleine
confiance de la part des électeurs
américains dans le système électoral
parce que on a bien vu tout à l'heure
lorsque nous discutions de l'élection de
présidentielle de 2001 ne sont pas
d'accord sur les fraudes ou pas les
fraudes ou si elles sont facilités par
le vote par correspondance ou pas mais
au résultat si vous voulez à l'arrivée
quand vous avez des citoyens qui
considère que voter n'est plus un acte
ou leur voix va être légitimement prise
en compte si vous perdez confiance dans
le système électoral les institutions
s'effrondre derrière donc sur le plan
strictement américain les choses sont en
fait très simple il faut mettre en place
des règles que tout le monde accepte et
que tout le monde respecte des règles
qui soient véritablement bipartisane
n'est pas simplement un c'est par un
seul parti maintenant c'est vrai que le
problème de joe biden si vous voulez
c'est que sur le plan de la politique
étrangère il y a malgré tout une
continuité entre obama entre trump et
entre
baden et cette continuité c'est de
parvenir à faire basculer le focus
principal de la politique étrangère de
l'europe et du théâtre on va dire euros
russo euros soviétique avant vers un
espace chinois et un espace sino et qui
correspondraient à l'asie du sud est
parce que pour eux c'est de là que va
venir le défi stratégique et c'est de là
que va venir le défi économique au 21e
siècle et les choses sont très très
difficiles à changer du fait également
que c'est vrai les démocraties sont
beaucoup plus difficiles à gérer que ne
sont les régimes autoritaires ou hutus
vient d'en haut ouais elles sont plus
fragiles bien sûr leur gauthier en plus
compliqué pour joe biden puisque lui il
est très impopulaire un an après sa
première année de mandat il n'a que 45 %
de popularité au sein des sondages trump
avait 35 % donc c'était encore moins
mais en dehors de trump il était quand
même tous le plus populaire que lui dont
comment expliquer cette impopularité de
drogba hayden alors que finalement il a
tout de même fait passer de plan de
relance à c'était plutôt au bi partisan
il a mis en place une politique
sanitaire qui me semble à peu près
décente parce que vous avez alors non
seulement vous avez le camp républicain
qui effectivement est vent debout contre
joe baydan à de rares exceptions près
mais vous avez aussi une partie du parti
démocrate qui est aussi extrêmement
virulente voir vigilant tout linverse
plutôt vis-à-vis de vis-à-vis de joe
biden donc il y a cette idée que joe by
dane et parfois prisonniers de ce camp à
gauche du parti démocrate et que compte
tenu aussi déséquilibre à la fois à la
chambre des représentants et du sénat il
n'a pas les mains libres et ils risquent
de les avoir encore moins 6 après les
élections de mi mandat les républicains
gagner il suffirait pas de grand chose
donc l'idée c'est que il est à la fois
le représentant de ce libéralisme owni
sage parle pour la droite disons une
grande partie de la droite et de
l'extrême libéralisme au sens américain
au sens américain défenseurs des
libertés tout à fait de l'autre côté il
est trop justement libéral cette fois au
sens économique pour toute une partie de
la gauche qui verrait bien une
intervention étatique plus musclée et
qui verrait bien aussi une sorte de
confirmation de leurs idées ou de leur
marotte qui est une marotte finalement
communautariste quand il s'agit de
représenter de façon encore une fois
communautariste des minorités donc vous
voyez que je termine d'amour le ce qui
me semble primordial dans l'histoire ça
n'est pas c'est bien sûr d'établir des
règles que tout le monde respecterai
mais cette fracture américaine n'est pas
seulement politique elle est
profondément culturel elle est aussi
dans les moyens d'éducation elle est
dans les moyens d'accès à la presse à la
lecture et tout cela eh bien c'est un
autre chantier c'est encore plus vaste
bien sûr que de recréer une confiance
qui est je suis tout à fait d'accord
nécessaires dans le domaine électoral
christiane les rapidement pourquoi est
il si impopulaire joe biden et pourquoi
justement ça va être compliqué pour lui
de réconcilier cette amérique c'est ce
qu'il a dit qu'il voulait faire il ya un
an
baboo pour la première partie de la
question c'est pas très compliqué du
tout en fait la raison c'est le concret
la raison c'est le sénat en fait
malheureusement dans ce pays le sénat ne
réprésente la citoyenneté d'une façon
égale donc on a deux sénateurs pour
chaque état que ce soit le new york la
californie qui sont très très peuplées
aussi peuplé que beaucoup de pays
européens
en même temps il ya 2 2 sénateurs pour
des états qui sont presque vides où il
n'y a presque personne qui vivent là
toute l'année donc on a des sénateurs
dans le parti démocratique qui ne sont
pas centriste ils sont conservateurs on
voit par exemple christine amas de
l'arizona où joe match de la virginie
occidentale et donc c'est pas une
division il s'agit pas d'une division
entre frères dardenne et
les membres rôle culte aux gauchistes
dans le parti démocrate en fait ce que
l'on voit maintenant c'est que il ya
beaucoup de progressistes qui était un
peu cynique au début qui qui la veulent
vraiment travailler avec joe biden dans
le sénat et dont le cros créé en même
temps on voit des conservateurs dont le
parti qui était qui s'appelait au moins
des centristes qui sont responsables
pour bloquer
tout ce que veut faire d'ohb allen dont
le concret et c'est pour ça je crois
qu'ils attendent eux dans deux sondages
très négatif sur scène parisienne parce
qu'ils donnent l'impression d'être
bloquée c'est ça que vous voulez dire
précisément et en fait contre mémoire
est précisément et puis c'est pas une
simple question d'être aperçus que m
bloqué mais en même temps où on voit
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui veulent
voir des résultats et si le sénat refuse
de donner des résultats au peuple et
bien c'est joe baleines en tant que
président qui reçoit
tout cela sans pression négative
charles-olivier il nous reste trois
minutes donald trump prépare-t-il un
retour en 2024 oui j'ai déjà répondu à
la question que par ce retour pour
terminer ce baquet sur président très
rapidement joe biden est impopulaire
parce que c'est politique sont
impopulaires et le sénat aux états unis
est une chambre essentiel je rappelle
que les états unis de par leur nom ce
sont des états qui se sont unis et
l'importance de chaque état au sein de
la des institutions est primordiale et
le sénat est là pour représenter les
états donc ce que j'entends de votre
intervenants qui est à washington parce
que le sénat n'est pas à majorité
démocrate soudain c'est devenu une
chambre qu'il faudrait se passer je
trouve ça extrêmement dangereux et pour
moi là il ya une vraie menace à la
démocratie américaine avait présenté un
recours en 2024 on n'a plus beaucoup de
temps oui oui prépare son retour je le
disais tout à l'heure c'est quand même
le personnage de milan du parti
républicain je pense qu'il veut sa
revanche il a une personnalité qui
commençait est surdimensionné et il a
avec lui la base du parti et à partir de
là il sera très difficile à qui que ce
soit de lui prendre la domination
francfort il y avait à faire du mans une
écart entre le la baisse de popularité
de 11 points en un an et la situation du
pays un croissance 2% un chômage à 4,9
alors pourquoi plutôt un bélier que des
milk embellie économique et fait
effectivement et puis vous l'avez dit de
réforme d'importantes une à 200
milliards quand même faire voter de 100
milliards c'est pas rien et l'une à 1200
milliards alors trois raisons très
rapide la première c'est peut-être un
problème de communication de joe biden
il a un discours quand même très négatif
encore il ya peu de temps c'était son
affirma prompt à lui il critiquait les
non vaccinés en disant je vous promets
une année épouvantable vous allez tous
mourir enfin c'était quand même tout le
monde s'est étonné de cette
communication est laconique deuxième
chose polarisation négative c'est à dire
qu'il a été élu aussi surtout contre
donald trump il ya qu' il fait très peu
de promesses positive qui parle à tous
les américains y compris au camp rouge
souvenez vous des grands présidents
démocrates comme clinton et bien lui
parlait aussi au corps républicain ça
c'est difficile à faire dans cette
amérique bipolaire elle est prévue quand
m aujourd'hui en même temps et peut-être
d'un mot de dire qu' il a quand même une
expérience politique qui lui permet de
jongler avec ces cycles de popularité en
se disant que la plupart des présidents
perdre de toute façon les élections mid
term avant d'être élu quatre ans plus
tard voilà il peut-être un retour donc
de donald trump en 2024 c'est ce qu'on
disait merci beaucoup gauthier merci
françois durpaire merci à vous et gérald
olivier merci à christian hanley puis
merci sonia dridi qui a démarré cette
émission avec nous à merci à tous
d'avoir suivi reste avec nous sur france
[Musique]